So these are my disclosures. You know, what I thought would be an interesting thing for this group, because like we heard, this is a AML very much based therapy, but it's something that isn't very common in sort of the matrix of how this trial worked is not very common.
So I thought it'd be a nice introduction to say, how are we doing things in AML in a more broad sense? And then it's nice that we'll look at some of the very fine granular aspects that are coming up in the future. And what's really good right now is that my timer hasn't started, so I can at least just keep going.
So what I'm going to talk about, what I'm going to talk about Myelomatch. So Myelomatch is this NCI sponsored initiative that's for both AML and MDS.
And many of you may have heard and seen some studies with what's called the BEAT AML trial, which is another broad trial.
That's sort of a nationwide trial. This is a little bit different in the sense that it's a bit broader, it covers a bit larger population.
And the thought is that if you can create a master screening protocol, and I'm going to just sort of plow through some of these for a moment, if you can create a master protocol where we can get everybody screened.
And not only get everybody screened with having a DNA and cytogenetics and mutational status, but then have a number of different trials underneath that, that patients would be eligible for.
You'd really not only get a DNA and cytogenetics and mutational status, but then have a number of different trials underneath that, that patients would be eligible for.
You'd really not only capture the entire AML population, but you'd also have numerous novel agents that fit certain mutational properties, because the bottom line is, as you've heard from most of the people here, it's really about coming through with targeted mutations now in AML.
We're breaking AML down from one disease where everyone just got the same chemotherapy to numerous separate diseases based on individual mutations.
And the concept is what we do is we get these protocol, we get these mutations.
And the key is all the molecular studies are done ideally within 72 hours, which isn't something that happens in the real world.
There's a lot of centers that it takes two weeks to get the molecular studies back.
So the key is the rapidity of getting this done.
And then they get this initial treatment that's a targeted treatment based upon their own mutational status.
It's kind of a personalized medicine type concept.
What then happens and what we're at now is we can then stratify after that to what's called Tier 2, which is called MRD, which you can see on the second line.
And that's how do we eradicate any disease and what's the best way to eradicate that.
So that has a series of trials that the patient can pass through depending on their MRD status.
And then there's a transplant trial after that to say, OK, now we've got them in MRD.
How do we get them to transplant?
And what's the best way to transplant?
There's some trials that actually are employing venetoclax that are going to be opened up in the transplant setting.
So that's sort of the basic pattern to say, how do we take such a diverse, broad group and make this available?
To them with rapid responses in terms of molecular studies.
So we looked at the first 500 patients and what we saw was that of the first 500 patients, some screen failed.
The screen failed may mean that they're just too sick to even wait for their studies to come back.
They just have to go on some type of dealer's choice treatment.
Now, what I didn't mention in the previous study is that in that dealer's choice treatment, if you don't, if this site doesn't have a particular study open,
they go on what's called the Tier Advancement Protocol, meaning that the site can put in what they feel is a standard.
And then they can go on to a different trial at a later state if they have that trial open, whether it's the MRD trial or the transplant trial.
But anyway, 76 patients, so about a sixth of the patients or so didn't have AML.
They had ALL, they had aplastic anemia, they had something else.
So they were tossed as well.
And we found that about 90% of these patients had AML and a good portion of these patients, about 10% had MDS.
Very heavily towards the white population.
And age range was about 63, which is very important because these trials have the cutoff of age 60, where we think of younger adult trials as age 60, older adult trials as over the age of 60.
I'm heading now the young adult trial, and I find it somewhat depressing that when we started this trial, I would have been in the younger category.
I think when we end the trial and publish something, I won't qualify for any of the trials that I'll be overseeing.
But this is really the take-home study, which is, can we take these studies and can we get results within 72 hours?
And what we found was, barring a few different screen fails or a few issues with individual samples, 95% of people were able to get the results within 72 hours, which is really an incredible breakthrough, because when we look at the BEAT AML study, which is sort of the other predecessor towards this, that goal was to get everything back within a week.
So 72 hours is really important to try to get the results quickly.
And then what we've also seen is, as this has moved forward, and it's been a slow process because the screening process is really slow.
And so there's a significant lag time.
But as you can see, it really started off with a very slow enrollment, but you can see the enrollment to each individual randomized trial has been increasing over time.
Now, what's really nice about this is we can look at a large volume of molecular data, and we can actually see what the molecular construct is for the general patient population, which will help us look towards the future to say, what can we use for this?
What can we use for different trials?
Where are our best opportunities?
So we can see in the AML group, 25% of these people have NPM1 mutations.
So this is really going to be very fertile ground to look at all of these men inhibitors that we have.
We see FLT3 in about 15%.
It somewhat mirrors the population.
But what's really interesting, and we were talking about this earlier just at breakfast, is when you look at the MDS population, almost 40% of patients have a TP53.
So this is obviously an incredibly fertile ground for us to say, what can we do?
What can we look at in terms of clinical trials?
Because these MDS trials are going to enroll very quickly.
For those of you who don't do AML, TP53 is sort of the holy grail of mutations.
It's the one that Tomas has been working on for a while, and we just haven't been able to find something that works.
It's kind of like, I think of it as like the Darth Vader or the New York Yankees of AML mutations.
You know, where are we in terms of what people are doing?
And I think this is interesting based on some of the data that Sasha talked about with the PARADIGM trial.
We looked and said,
all right, the people that are getting treated off protocol, what are they receiving?
And we find that 62% of people are getting intensive chemotherapy still, 38% are getting HMA-VEN.
And what's interesting is this is all before PARADIGM.
And I think there's going to be some significant changes.
What I was kind of shocked with is that in the patients that were age 60 to 75, almost half of them were still getting intensive chemotherapy.
And I think that's going to remarkably change based on the data that Sasha put forward with the PARADIGM trial.
You know, there are currently five open trials.
There are about two more trials.
There's the young adult, the young adult good risk trial, which Sella Houston is in charge of.
And that's going to be open next week, hopefully next week, maybe two weeks.
There's another IDH trial that we're expecting to open in the next couple of weeks.
But these are the five trials that are open.
And so it's nice to see these enrolling.
And they're enrolling now at a pretty good clip now that more centers have these open.
And so conclusion, you know,
Myelomatch, as of two weeks ago, we just broke the 1,000th patient that's been screened for that protocol.
So that's really important to just see how this has ramped up over the past really six months or so.
We've been able to meet the turnaround goal of turnaround time goal of about 72 hours.
And we currently have five trials open.
But in the end, we're looking at about 17, 18 trials and sort of a mix and match.
So when we look at, for example, the FLIT3 trial, the FLIT3 trial in the elderly, which is randomizing to,
we'll be able to pick the winner of that and then move another drug into that trial as well.
So this is going to have subsequent trials moving forward.
So I thank you all for your time.
This has been a Herculean effort by a lot of people involved in this entire study.
But appreciate it.